hey guys Pete here today I'm going to
talk about Sir Arthur Dayne the sword of
the morning well at least one of the
swords of the morning this is primarily
history so there's no real spoilers
about current events although if you
haven't watched Game of Thrones season 6
yet then this will kind of spoil that so
with the season 6 DVDs they added a
history in lore about Arthur Dayne which
doesn't really bring any new information
but it's kind of odd that they put it in
there I mean he did play a part in brans
flashbacks of the Tower of joy as he was
the dual wielding Kingsguard that was at
the tower that Ned and Helen eventually
got the better of so I guess you could
say that his backstory was important for
that reason so that you can learn who
that guy was that was guarding Lyanna
stark at the Tower of joy but I think
it's likely that there's more to it than
that which I should mention is totally
weird because Sir Arthur Dayne only ever
wielded dawn I mean he's got the coolest
oared in Westeros so he's never been
said to have wielded two swords at the
same time so that's a show only kind of
thing there so the history and lore goes
over his story which I'll recap really
quickly the one thing about Arthur Dayne
is that you know he's not really
mentioned that much in the books but
he's always mentioned with really high
regard bran recalls that Ned said that
Arthur Dayne was the finest Knight he
ever saw and that he would have killed
him if it wasn't for Helen Helen Reid
and this new clip is actually narrated
by the actor who played the young Ned
Stark so he tells the exact same story
first theory tells the legend of how
Starfall the ancestral seat of house
Dayne was founded the legend is that the
first Dayne found a magic stone that
fell from the sky like a shooting star
and that's where they actually built
star fall and he mentions that this is a
fantastic story but that the house Dayne
has a relic to prove it which is the
ancestral blade dawn the quick story of
dawn is that it is it's a really old
sword that was forged from the meteorite
and it has a lot of magical
properties it predates Valyrian steel by
quite a while but it has the same sort
of properties although in the books it
looks a lot different it's actually milk
white they say and in the TV show
obviously they stay went away from that
a little bit but it's a magical sword
it's a famous sword and one of the many
things that is curious about how stain
is is that it's not passed from father
to his oldest son like most families do
with their ancestral blades instead
there's someone who's called the sword
of the morning when someone emerges to
be a great warrior if no one does then
the sword stays on the mantle and no one
uses it so Dawn's a whole nother subject
all by itself and we'll get into that
more but for now let's continue on with
Arthur Dayne story so young Ned tells us
that about a story whenever while
serving on the Kingsguard for King Aerys
so Arthur Dayne befriended the small
folk so that he could track down and
defeat the Kingswood Brotherhood this
was a band of people who was sort of
going around and terrorizing the
countryside and no one could stop them
because the small folk were basically
protecting them by using diplomacy and
talking to them and finding out what
they needed he was able to track down
the Kingswood Brotherhood x' leader the
smiling knight who he defeated in single
combat they don't mention this in the
history and lore but at that same time
he did Knight Jaime Lannister who we
know obviously became a sworn brother of
the Kingsguard down the road young Ned
goes from the story of the smiling
Knight to talking about how even though
they fought on opposite sides he
respected him he goes on to say that he
wanted to be him that all boys wanted to
be him at that time and that ultimately
he killed him we see a shot of Ned
holding dawn soaked in blood and we see
Arthur on the ground we had more of this
in the actual flashback scene with Brian
earlier where we see Ned pick up dawn
and slice him and really up until this
point the details about Sir Arthur Danes
death weren't really known when Ned
remembers that he doesn't really talk
about how he died he just tells brand
that
after Damon would have killed him if it
wasn't for Howland Reed so if we take
what happened in the show and in this
history and lore clip to be what will
happen in the books then we can say for
sure that the theory about Arthur Dayne
still being alive wouldn't be right this
is actually a theory that there's a
couple versions of it around but because
it basically boils down to the idea that
because it never says how he died that
perhaps something happened where Ned at
Holland got the upper hand and therefore
Arthur Dayne decided to fake his own
death more or less he you know he he
would have to give up the sword go into
hiding Ned and Helen would have to build
the burial site to make it look like he
was dead and then returned onto Starfall
to cover the whole thing up so those
theories were around for a long time and
I think this kind of clears it up at
least for what we can expect to see in
the television show but one of the
reasons why these theories were so
popular is because there just isn't that
much information about Dayne in the
books I mean he's obviously an important
character who's mentioned but mysterious
just the same I mean his whole family
sort of is if you think about it now the
show never did the young edrick Dame who
goes by Ned and the books he was in the
Brotherhood without banners and Arya
actually met him on her way through the
Riverlands he's currently the head of
house Dayne Lord of house Dayne but he's
also kind of a mystery as well like no
one knows what his father's name was he
was Arthur Dean's older brother so you
know it was his his Shara and Illyria
were her sisters but nobody knows who he
was it's also kind of odd that his name
is Eric but he goes by Ned which
everyone knows is the name of the man
who slain his his uncle who was the
sword of the morning the warrior of
their house so that's a bit odd so he
was in the books he traveled with beric
Dondarrion because Spaak was married to
his aunt
Illyria who I just mentioned and he
followed them around until Barrack
actually died the Brotherhood without
banners for the last time but like I
said the show never had him as a
character but like I said it's it's
really strange with these guys because
is there mentioned as an important thing
but I can't even think of anyone who's
ever actually seen star fall in the
books like it's there but as far as at
least the point-of-view characters I
can't think of any of them that have
actually visited star fall it is in
Dorne though I mean so there are lots of
places in the books that we've never
been to but other than Ned going there
before the series actually started after
Robert's rebellion nobody's been there
so that's what makes Sir Arthur Dayne
such a mysterious character and an
interesting character at the same time
we have a lot of accounts of things that
he did or or the way that he was we have
a lot of important and interesting
connections
he was Rhaegar Targaryen best friend
Ser Barristan knew him from being in the
Kingsguard he trains her Jaime Lannister
he stayed behind at the tower joy to
protect Lyanna Stark until Ned and Helen
killed him in the history and lore clip
young Ned says that he respected him to
the end that he knew that he wouldn't
follow along with Rhaegar taking Liana
if he wasn't just following his vows so
on top of being a great warrior he is
considered to be this true Knight you
know who does what he's supposed to do
and his chivalrous and so on and so
forth so what does this characters
purpose if he's not still alive which I
don't think he is those theories are out
the window what is up with these
mysterious Danes you know they're their
ancestral seat is at the place where
this meteorite supposedly crashed to the
ground
nobody's really gone there in any of the
books ashara dayne is this you know
magically beautiful mysterious character
that pops up at the tourney of Harrenhal
only to commit suicide off screen later
on by jumping out of a tower of course
there's theories there where she had
slept with Ned or possibly Brandon I'm
kind of in the NED camp but supposedly
one of the Starks impregnated her then
we got the the leader of the house now
the lord of the house whose father was
just the only in
if again sibling out of the whole bunch
you know the one that nobody even knows
his name because he didn't do anything
except for father this kid
Sir Arthur Dayne is this legendary
Knight who makes his last stand
protecting the air of his King who he's
sworn to serve but was also his best
friend who he wasn't with at the Battle
of the Trident because he followed
orders
you know the whole thing the whole
Robert's rebellion may have gone
differently if Rhaegar hadn't made the
decision to put his three strongest
Kingsguard at the tower of joy to
protect Liana so you know they're woven
into the story and it makes you wonder
why they're there and what is the
purpose that we haven't really figured
out yet and I think it will eventually
all come down to dawn that their house
ancestral blade when asked about it
George our Martin has said that it's
just sitting in Starfall waiting for the
next sword of the morning to come along
that would seem to indicate at least at
this point that edrick Dayne you know
young Ned is not going to be the sword
of the morning or he's not ready to be
the sword of the morning yet but I mean
there is that possibility he did he did
leave you know the Brotherhood without
banners once Lady Stoneheart took over
so he may have gone back and we might
find out more about them there but you
know it just it just seems like an
open-ended mystery that there has to be
a greater purpose you know it's sort of
on the same lines as Howland Reed or you
know the Green Man and the Isle of faces
which I've done videos about recently
there's no reason to inject them into
the story if you're not going to use
them for something big and that is the
one thing that really stands out from
the history and lore is it's just like
they really emphasize the blade Don and
how magical and important it is but just
like I said jut you know George says
it's sitting on the mantle and they show
it they're actually twice in the in
history and lore clip which makes you
even think about it more like they're
almost trolling us with it like yet this
is important but we're not going to tell
you why which the obvious conclusion
that most people theorize is is that
it's somehow going to be Lightbringer
which i mean that's definitely a whole
nother video so you know I'm not going
to get in that here but
it is the oldest sword that we know of
that has this kind of power like you
know that as strong as Valyrian steel
and then the TV show did that little
putting it at the end of the bed and
sort of framing the shot with it
whenever young Ned goes to still Leon
aside and when you know at her deathbed
so let me know what you guys think in
the comments I will probably do a video
about dawn and you know all the theories
that surround that I mean it's a pretty
pretty done to death kind of thing but
it's interesting if you don't know about
it let me know and I'll you know
definitely work on that video in the
near future please like the video if you
enjoyed it and tell me if you have any
sir Arthur Dayne theories that I didn't
think about in the comments the book
giveaway is still going on and we're
getting close so make sure you subscribe
and leave a comment
when I hit 28,000 subscribers I will
send one of the commenters from one of
the videos that's included in this
giveaway a copy of a game of Thrones
20th anniversary edition the Illustrated
one that just came out recently so make
sure like I said you subscribe and like
and comment on the video for your chance
to win thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon